okay now for our latest from our
investigation into a large-scale money
laundering operation spanning southern
Africa and the Middle East the Al
Jazeera investigative unit has uncovered
evidence implicating high-ranking
diplomats in Zimbabwe and some of South
Africa's top Banks the gold Mafia
invited undercover reporters to visit
their headquarters in Dubai where rival
gangs launder vast amounts of money
Alexander James has its report
kamlesh patney is a notorious gold
dealer he laundered US money using gold
that he sells in Dubai he shows
undercover reporters earnings from one
store that's the cash is this US Dollars
rival gangs are competing to clean up
what journalists posing as Chinese
gangsters say is 1.2 billion dollars of
dirty cash so every day of uh coming yes
every day the impression you know like
10 million
wants the reporters to join his existing
money laundering setup
yeah it's not like you know somebody can
a question or anything but then it
becomes
that is the laundromat was finished
washing like now then you can invest in
what you want Dubai has set themselves
up for being the middle of the gold
trade the key to being a money
laundering Haven is you have to have the
financial infrastructure and they had
LAX laws and no enforcement
Alistair Mathias is also based in Dubai
he uses gold to clean money for corrupt
politicians
is better than any currency
anyway
[Music]
for the most part
he plans to clean the dirty cash through
his gold Refinery
Dubai is held by a friend of mine in
trust me it can do I can do about 150
kilos of their body you can pay it
through the refinery you know but I'll
play with the paperwork I'll make it
look like you gave me gold or something
like that ubertangel is a Zimbabwean
Ambassador who has offered to launder
money through gold
he recently spoke to International
delegates in Dubai about investing in
Zimbabwe free from corruption
People to People diplomacy in their
voice individuals who Trust
with little or no corruption or demands
of Rights Angel is asking for two
hundred thousand dollars to arrange a
meeting between Zimbabwe's president
Emerson manangagwa and Al jazeera's
undercover team that guy doesn't take
bribes
oh no
no one
there's a big difference in appreciating
somebody and probably you know we at
this level people don't brag nobody
there is somebody saying uh thank you
for everything that you were doing for
us and the big difference
Angel says president Managua can help
with the money laundering for a fee
240 million US Dollars and that's his
money there's not somebody else it's not
the party this is money so when
somebody's got money to spend on
you you give him one million is like a
sleepy in the first kamlesh patney
denied involvement in any form of money
laundering and said that he had offered
to deal with funds he knew originated
from illegal sources Alistair Mathias
said that he had never laundered money
or gold nor offered to do such things he
said he had never owned any refineries
in Dubai the other parties featured did
not respond to our inquiries Alexander
James Al Jazeera
and Alexander is in London for us now
good to see you Alexander so your third
piece into this investigation is about
to go out on Al Jazeera what can we
expect from this installment
well in this installment of the series
uh we follow the evidence to Dubai and
we find all the gold Mafia at work there
and it's the destination for the
laundered money but it's also a
destination for the golden it's where
the gold goes to get laundered to Gold
that has uh association with sanctions
or comes from other dubious Origins it
needs to be refined it needs to be
melted down again and turned into a
product that is easier to sell on the
international markets and that's what
happens here and we find that the gold
Mafia are really controlling uh both
sides of the supply chain they control
the exporters in southern Africa and
they control the importers in Dubai and
this allows them to disguise very easily
what is going on in the process and
makes it very hard for the authorities
to ask questions about what is really
going on too so the goal that they're
exporting there needs to be turned into
a marketable product it's sold to the
refineries in Dubai and with a stamp of
the Dubai Refinery it's a product of
divine it's no longer associated with
with the sanctions of that face
Zimbabwe's leaders or the issues facing
the country that it's come from
bring a piece like this must be quite
challenging uh we're going to show some
pictures in a moment I mean can you talk
us through exactly what they involved
sure so our undercover reporters were
actually invited to Dubai by one of the
bosses of the gold leaf Mafia himself
kamlesh patney
and he gave our undercover reporters a
tour of his operations there of his
businesses not just in Gold but Diamond
Traders uh Securities Traders
um international travel agencies and
presented all of these businesses as a
way to launder the money or way to
invest that laundered money so really
given an Insider's view of uh his his
ability to operate there and I think it
also shows how safe the gold Mafia are
there he was able to operate freely uh
is able to operate freely and showed
undercover reporters round offices that
he has in the in the center of the
Commodities uh Trading Zone there so
it's a it's a really unique insight into
the gold mafia's presence in Dubai and
just how safe they are to operate there
is as a result of your journalism as a
result of your investigation the
Zimbabwe government has said that they
are investigating several individuals in
the gold Mafia how does that make you
feel
well it appears that they're going after
some of the mid low level facilitators
in the laundering or the smuggling
operations I mean what our investigation
shows and what the evidence shows is
that the gold Mafia exists there from
with the patronage from from the very
top that's the gold Mafia are protected
uh by the the ruling establishment in
Zimbabwe and what's being said clearly
doesn't indicate that they're going
after the Gold Mafia bosses themselves
and you saw in the the uh news clip
there or the Ambassador Hubert Angel uh
talking about this 200 000 payments that
was going to give the the um get the
president's blessing for the money
laundering operation that are undercover
reporters were were suggesting
is very clear to describe that as an
appreciation it's it's certainly not a
bribe because the president has so much
money that uh that 250 sorry that two
hundred thousand dollars
barely scratches the surface so so when
you when you've got an individual that's
going to invest um in excess of 200
million in their own election campaign
of their own money I think you've got to
question the ability of State
institutions to effectively go after
corruption when there is that level of
individual control uh in the government
process that's our investigation and the
evidence we present is showing
fascinating stuff Alexander James uh
good to speak to you speaking to us
there the reporter on that investigation
speaking to us there from London
thank you well Zimbabwe's minister of
information says the authorities are
committed to upholding local and
international laws relating to financial
transactions the trade of gold and other
Precious Minerals
government takes the allegations
which are raised in this documentary
services
in this direction
to Institute investigations into issues
raise
[Music]
and found to have engaged in Acts of
corruption
proud or any form of crime will face the
full growth of